[تصفيق]
ايلون ماسك يتدخل في الحرب ويوقف الهجوم
الاوكراني يا للعجب وبريطانيا تطلق
طائراتها باتجاه روسيا وتطلب التدخل من
الهند والكيان الاسرائيلي يكسر القاعده
ويوجه طعنه غدر للدب الروسي فكيف سيرد
بوتين هذه المره والمانيا تتدارك الموقف
وتتراجع قليلا بعد التهديدات الروسيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي يتحدى روسيا مجددا
والامم المتحده ترضخ لشروط
بوتينسكي يستغيثك العاده لا وجود لنا في
السماء انقذونا يطلق وحش المحيطات ويعلن
التحدي ومن دروس فرنسا في النيجر ها هي
واشنطن تستفيد وتعيد ترتيب اوراقها من
جديد وجيش بوركينا فاسو يصل الى ميامي
تتمسك بامل ضائع تحاول اوكرانيا التحالف
مع ايا كان وكسب ودي اي في العالم فالغريق
يتشبث بقشه وعدو عدوي هو صديقي كما يقول
المثل وهو الحال الاوكراني يا ساده تتجه
البوصله الاوكرانيه نحو اغنى اغنياء
العالم عم انه الملياردير الامريكي ايلون
ماسك والذي اعلن انه في عام 2022 كان قد
تلقى طلبا عاجلا من الحكومه الاوكرانيه
لتفعيل اقمارلينك على طول الطريق باكمله
الى ميناء سيفوستبول في القرن من اجل
اغراق معظم الاسطول الروسي الراسي هناك
ولكن ماسك رد قائلا اذا وافقت على الطلب
فستكون سبايس اكس متورطه في عمل حربي كبير
وتصعيد للصراع ليعود الاوكران خائبين من
اقرب الحلفاء الخيبه الاوكرانيه كانت من
جانب الكيان الاسرائيلي ايضا والذي احدث
قطيعه وتوترا مع كييف لتسعه اشهر لكن
اليوم ها هو رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
يبحث مع الرئيس الاوكراني
تل ابيب ومنها مساعده اللاجئين الاوكران
في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
لمراقبه وكبح روسيا في المنطقه زعما بان
روسيا قد تهاجم السفن التي تنقل الحبوب
الم يسمع سوناك الرد الروسيه من قبل لان
السفن في البحر الاسود اهداف مشروعه ومع
هذه الخطوه اتجهت لندن نحو خطوه اخرى وذلك
بدعوه سوناك على هامش قمه مجموعه العشرين
بين نيودلهي نظيره الهندي
لاستخدام نفوذه بانهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا
لكن وعلى عكس الانجليزي تماما ها هي وزيره
خارجيه الالمانيه انارينا بربوك تعلن انه
لا يمكن ارسال صواريخ تاورس بعيده المدى
الى اوكرانيا بسرعه فما الذي جعل برلين
تتان هكذا التريث الالماني انتقل الى
الامم المتحده فقد ذكرت صحيفه بلد
الالمانيه ان الامين العام للامم المتحده
عن استعداد المنظمه الدوليه لقبول كافه
شروط الجانب الروسي للعوده الى تنفيذ صفقه
الحبوب يبدو ان حرب البطون الجائعه ولم
يبقى الا ان يعطي بوتين موافقته اليس كذلك
دعونا نكمل حيث لا تزال حرب الغرب البارده
مع روسيا بين كر وفر وهنا صرح رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شرم ميشيل بان الاتحاد الاوروبي
حقق ما اسماه تقدما على مكافحه الالتفاف
على العقوبات ضد روسيا ويروه مهما للغايه
بالنسبه للاتحاد بينما كشفت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
اضافيه لاوكرانيا بقيمه 600 مليون دولار
وتشمل الحزمه انواعا مختلفه من الذخائر
ومعدات لازاله الالغاز
يا ابناء العم سام وصدق من قال
سيقاتلنا حتى اخر جندي اوكراني لكن ذلك لم
يكن كافيا بالنسبه
والذي قال ان اوكرانيا تحتاج الى المزيد
من المعدات الغربيه خاصه المقاتلات
الحديثه لتسريع الهجوم المضاد وتابع لا
وجود لنا في السماء لكن روسيا موجوده
فانهم يوقفوننا من السماء انهم يوقفون
هجومنا المضاد والان ميدانيا حيث اعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها صدت الهجمات
الاوكرانيه على محاور القتال الاساسيه سته
وحسنت مواقعها على محور كوفيانس فيما بلغت
خسائر العدو نحو 630 جنديا خلال اليوم وها
هو المصدر يتحدث كما تشاهدونه في الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه من جهتها افادت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه تصدت في مسيره فوق اوديسا
مضيفه ان الجيش الاوكراني حقق تقدما جنوب
روبوتين انه يواصل التقدم على جبهه جنوبا
في اتجاه ميليتو بول واليكم المصدر من
جههها افاد الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه تتصدت لسته عشره
مسيره فوق اوديسا كما افادت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان الجيش حقق تقدما جنوب
روبوتيني وبخمت وانه يواصل التقدم على
جبهه جنوبا باتجاه
فيما قال مصدر في مركز العلاقات العامه
بجهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي ان رجال
المخابرات احبطوا محاوله تفجير سكه الحديد
في القرن حضر لها احد سكان سيفوستبول
باعاز من استخبارات اوكرانيا لترد وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه انها تمكنت من تدمير
مستودع ذخيره للقوات الروسيه في قريه ميرو
نيفزكي بمنطقه
ليخرج الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ويهنئ
سكان الجمهوريه دونيتسكو جميع الروس
بمناسبه الذكرى السنويه 80 لتحرير دومباس
من الغزاه الفاشيين خلال الحرب الوطنيه
العظمى بحسب تعبي وبالعوده الى اخبار
الهند فقد صرحت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
بان الدول مجموعه السبعه تمارس ضغوطا على
الهند لتضمين الوثائق الختامي لمجموعه
العشرين مواقفها الاحاديه تجاه النزاع في
اوكرانيا لننتقل الى حرب المال والاعمال
حيث صرح رئيس الحكومه الروسيه ميخائيل بان
ايرادات الميزانيه الروسيه من النفط
والغاز انطلاقا من شهر سبتمبر الجاري بدات
تتجاوز بشكل كبير معدلات العام الماضي
2022 واشار الى ان الميزانيه الروسيه حققت
في نهايه الشهر الماضي فاذا قدره 230
مليار روبل اي حال مليارين
و380 مليون دولار مشددا على ان الاقتصاد
الروسي يتكيف مع التحديات الحاليه الاحداث
والتطورات اعلن سفير كوريا الشماليه في
موسكو سين هونشو ان بلاده تتبع سياسته
الاسلحه النوويه مقابل الاسلحه الجنوبيه
وسياسه الرد بالمثل على المواجهات
الامريكيه في المنطقه من جهه اخرى فقد
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه في الثامن من الشهر
الجاري انها قامت ببناء اول غواصه نوويه
تكتيكيه هجوميه جديده قادره علشان هجوم
نووي تحت الماء ووفقا لصحيفه
[موسيقى]
حضور الزعيم كيم جونغ اون الذي قال ان
التسلح النووي للبحريه يمثل تحديا عاجلا
في العصر لم يعد من الممكن تاخيره او
ابطائه بعدما حدث لفرنسا في النيجر اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان الولايات
المتحده بدات تجري عمليه اعاده تموضع
لقوتها في النيجر في اجراء احترازي بما
افادت التقارير باصول وحدات من جيش
بوركينا فاسو الى النيجر وقال المجلس
العسكري الحاكم الى انتشار الوحدات جيش
بوركينا فاسو ياتي ضمن شراكه تجمع البلدين
في مجال التدريب العسكري ذكر ت مجله نزويك
الامريكيه ان الجيش الامريكي يسعى حاليا
الى تطوير قاعده عسكريه في جزيره باتل في
الفلبين لتعزيز وجوده العسكري بشكل قوي في
شرق اسيا وقالت المجله ان الخطوه
الامريكيه تعزز وجود الاستراتيجي قرب
جزيره تايوان وهو امر سيثير حفيظه الصين
[موسيقى]